Чому жінки заробляють менше?
Це не міф, а досі реальність: жіночі зарплати
залишаються низькими, чоловічі - зростають.
Це Ева. Вона заробляє в Німеччині
на 21 відсоток менше, ніж чоловік.
До того ж, у неї значно нижчі шанси
отримати, приміром, службове авто.
Але чому?
Поглянемо на ситуацію кілька десятиліть тому.
Після Другої світової через нестачу чоловіків
жінки мусили взятися за важку чоловічу роботу.
Відповідно, стали гучнішими їхні вимоги
справедливої оплати праці.
Боротьба за рівноправ'я з чоловіками була не без успіху.
Утім, через німецьке "економічне диво" знову
змінилися суспільні ролі чоловіка і жінки.
Принаймні у Західній Німеччині Ева як дружина
могла собі дозволити бути домогосподаркою,
аби дбати про кухню...
дітей...
та чоловіка.
Суспільство та закони розцінювали чоловіка
як годувальника, який приносить додому гроші.
Таке уявлення про роль чоловіка та жінки
панувало десятиліттями і донині
має вплив на ринок праці.
Ева вирішила працевлаштуватися на типову жіночу роботу -
вона працює у відділі кадрів.
Професії у галузі програмування, природничих наук
та технологій її не цікавлять.
У цьому, власне, коріння проблеми:
типово жіночі професії оплачуються гірше.
Приміром, медсестра або вихователька
заробляють менше, ніж автомайстер.
До того ж, свою кар’єру їй доведеться перервати
для того, аби завести сім'ю та дітей, а пізніше
працювати лише неповний день.
У кріслі керівника вона швидше за все не опиниться.
Якесь замкнуте коло!
Дослідники вирахували, що різницю в зарплатні чоловіків і жінок
вдаться усунути лише через 170 років.
Таким чином лише у 2187 році
Ева зможе заробляти стільки, скільки чоловік.